wait can i say uh say whatever you want
i want to be one of the greatest players
to ever play the game i didn't say that
[Music]
music gets me through everything for
just going into games if i don't have
music on i'm not locked in my earliest
memories of basketball were around five
through eight
around seven my mom trained me she won a
national championship with notre dame
she played in the league for five years
she's a head coach for notre dame right
now she was a coach with the memphis
grizzlies which is amazing just to be a
black female in the nba
[Music]
going into my freshman year high school
yeah i wanted to make
varsity did you make varsity freshman
year i didn't actually it kind of hit me
because i'm just like i know i'm better
than the guys on varsity i played like
maybe 15 minutes varsity my freshman
year i played in a playoff game
[Applause]
it was the first time i'd seen a lot of
people in the stands and like i had
jitters in my stomach
when i get out there
i airball like two times
and then it was like okay we ended up
losing that game
and just i could just see everybody's
faces like after we lost and it was just
a terrible feeling
and then the next day
i'm right back in the gym
my junior year i went to a purdue elite
camp
and i played really well and i ended up
getting my first offer after that couple
weeks i got notre dame offer that was
amazing and then i got to offer from
butler to not be ranked highly it didn't
really like phase me at all
and when i got to purdue it's just like
i'm here now
so now i've got to get to another level
so whatever i did just like had that
focus and i just took off
and i was able to show that you know i'm
jayne ivy star player
music just cures your mind even off the
court it just makes everything okay when
i'm on the court hardcore rap it just
brings out a certain passion listen to a
lot of nba young boy
really heavy on him listen to tupac
usually before games you know you have
to have that passion when you're on the
court
[Music]
do you have my phone
i actually have my my goals like on my
screensaver um some of the goals i have
this year definitely going to get
drafted after that i want to win summer
league mvp definitely want to win rookie
of the year lead my team to the playoffs
in the nba championship for sure win the
mvp all-star more than just one time and
by the end of my career top 15 scout 50
and 600
[Music]
every morning i just look at him
you know when i'm done playing this game
i want to be one of the greatest ever
touch of basketball